foreign
we gotten too obsessed
um as a culture with goals yeah I get in
in my old world in the University
setting
like you you used to earn a master's
degree on the way to a PhD and all was
where was like somebody handing you a
cup of water on a marathon like you're a
lifetime scholar and we're just gonna
pause and recognize look how far you've
come
and you got the rest of your life to do
this now they become destinations right
I'm gonna go get this certification so
that I can tell the world look how look
how much I know look how many classes I
sat through and I feel like everything's
about a goal here and a goal here and a
goal here as a place to start instead of
saying no what if sleeping better was
your goal or what about having a better
marriage was your goal and if you pulled
that thread long enough you probably
should work out you should move your
body right yeah what's that phenomenon
there's a term for it where
um you would see this in athletes like
they train their whole life to compete
in the Olympics yes then they get to the
Olympics they win gold and then they get
depressed oh I fall off the map yeah
because their identity was that yeah
yeah that's what happens with a lot of
people you'll see people lose at 30
pounds I'm here
uh oh yeah what do I do now like this is
I don't know if I could do this I don't
enjoy this
um so yeah I think goals are are fine
but I don't think we should worship
goals I think it's really important
to figure out how to enjoy the process
you know because then you're always
going to want to you're always going to
want to do that and part of that is what
how you go into it yeah how do I go into
this am I taking care of me or am I
punishing me is it because I love me or
is it because I hate me you know why am
I doing this if you go into it the right
way and then once you understand that by
the way once you go into the right way
there's more right then we can discuss
the mechanisms and the most effective
ways and what's going to give you the
most bang for your buck and all that
stuff which everybody wants to talk
about that's all minor stuff right and
we'll get there we can get there we'll
talk about all that but you got to go
into it the right way if you go into it
the right way then the stuff I can talk
about the mechanisms uh that work and
that help
um then they become very effective in
the parallels with dealing with your
marriage or with mental health is the
exact same like if you go into a
disagreement with your with with my wife
to win we've both lost right or if I go
in to show her where she needs we both
lost if I go in like trying to help this
relationship it's totally different
proposition right absolutely it's 100
the same thing and
um
I this again I I found so much value in
working with clients who had therapists
and you know I guess my Saving Grace was
I cared so much about helping my clients
that I was able to question my own
methods when they weren't successful so
at least it dissolved that part of my
ego where I'd say okay this isn't
working
I really care about this person like
what's going on so I'd work with these
therapists and I'd ask them questions
and like you know how do I communicate
to this person I remember once I had a
client my first first time having a
client that told me they had an eating
disorder I had somebody who was
recovering
um anorexic and uh just I I you know
thankfully I did I say okay you're
working with a therapist I need to talk
is it okay if I communicate with them so
that I can know the right ways to
approach whatever so talk to this person
they said okay
um don't talk about weight don't talk
about body fat percentage don't talk
about
uh how they look focus on their
performance
and I remember it's like a light bulb oh
yeah let's just see if they would skip
them strong yeah let's just focus on
strength the side effect of which being
you're gonna have to feel better yeah
yeah you gotta eat if you're gonna get
stronger that's right and it worked it
was so effective now you could get
obsessed with that as well but it was a
wonderful segue from body focus to
Performance to all right now I'm gonna
take care of myself
um but yeah that's that's the biggest
thing and and what we've done
there's a few different reasons why we
we failed to solve this one is the how
we go into it I hate myself and then the
fitness space and the health space
capitalizes on that it's very effective
very powerful short-term motivator if
you're hating yourself right now I can
sell you something real quick you know
in fact in sales I talk about pain
points if you ever take a marketing
course they'll tell you find a person's
pain points and Hammer I never thought
though we're creating them right yeah
let's create a pain point and then solve
it right oh yeah oh create it find it
get that pain point and and you know
hammer on that and they'll buy your
product right so there's that uh the
other part is the the motivation model
okay which is and fitness loves this
right the newest class oh my God it's so
exciting Urban Cowboy hip-hop dance
class whatever it's new you know new
exercise machine it's so fun yeah
um and I get it we all love the feeling
of motivation
um I've never had to convince a client
to exercise or eat right when they're
motivated right it's the other times so
we have to learn how to develop skills
of discipline
that stick with us
forever